[موسيقى]
بعد النجاح الكبير في استضافه البطولات
الرياضيه واخرها كاس العالم بدات قطر
باستقطاب الزوار من كل مكان لتدخل قائمه
الدول المتقدمه في السياحه الرياضيه صراحه
قطر كثير بتجنن بلد كثير منظمه مرتبه
الشعب اللي فيها جدا متعاون وتعاملهم جدا
جدا لطيف والله نعم جاي على المباراه
واشكر قطر وشعب قطر وحكومه قطر على هذا
التنظيم المميز الجميل جدا صدقا انه الشعب
القطري شعب مضياف شعب جميل جدا اجواء جدا
رائعه يعني نحن نغبط قطر على هذا التنظيم
الجميل الرائع وتاتي كاس اسيا لتضيف لقطر
نجاحا اخر والله ما شاء الله البلد كثير
مرتبه كثير نظيفه اي كان استقبالهم كثير
حلو والحمد لله يعني به نمشي بالاسواق
واقف
ويعني مبسوطين كاننا قاعدين بالاردن
واصبحت دوله قطر خلال الاعوام الماضيه
وجهه سياحيه رياضيه تحل على ارضها
الجماهير الرياضيه من انديه ورياضيين
ومشجعين واتحادات تستمتع باجواء معتدله في
وقت تسود فيه الثلوج اقاع كثيره حول
العالم واحنا لسه لسه واصلين من عمان
الحين واصل من عمان حتى الشباب يعني نروح
الفندق نرتاح وكذا قلتهم لا بنطلع سوق
واقف وبعدين بنطلع نمر وكذا والصباح مره
ثانيه بنطلع مره ثانيه والله والله حلو
دوحه احب قطر كثير وايد لان دوحه شايفها
هي مهتمه بالسياحه وايد وتطورت سياحتها
خاصه من كاس عالم والحين كاس اسيا جميله
وايد والله
وناس امس رحت قطر
وايران
بالثمامه والله خوش مباراه والله وياتي
الاهتمام القطري بالسياحه الرياضيه نظرا
الى ما تتمتع به الرياضه من قدره على
توحيد الشعوب وخلق لغه تواصل واهتمام
مشترك بين الافراد من مختلف الجنسيات
يتوائم مع رؤيتها
[موسيقى]